en este vídeo vamos a fijarnos en la
hibridación sp3 que podemos hallar en el
metano y en el metano así que vamos a
empezar con el metano verdad esto es ch4
y si queremos dibujar una estructura de
puntos para el metano podríamos empezar
con el carbono verdad el carbono tiene
sus 4 electrones de valencia y luego
ponemos los 4 hidrógenos que están
alrededor de este carbono verdad y cada
uno de esos hidrógenos tiene un electrón
de valencia déjenme ponerlo un poco más
cercano
tenemos estos cuatro electrones perdón
cuatro hidrógenos con su electrón verdad
ahí tenemos una estructura de puntos
pero es una estructura de puntos de
louis verdad y usualmente lo que vemos
es algo así tenemos un carbono con
cuatro líneas que conectan a los
hidrógenos verdad
y esto es más o menos lo que observamos
y en el metano cada uno de estos enlaces
son equivalentes en términos de cosas
como por ejemplo la longitud de los de
los enlaces y la energía así que los
cuatro electrones de valencia del
carbono que
que dejen por ejemplo primero remarcar
los estos cuatro electrones que están
alrededor del carbono los podemos traer
a esta tabla que he puesto aquí así que
podemos poner dos electrones en el 1s de
verdad aquí tenemos dos electrones en el
1 s 2 electrones en el 2 s
y finalmente tenemos 2 electrones para
cada uno de estos orbitales de verdad y
por supuesto estamos suponiendo que ya
conoce sobre configuración electrónica
ok así que vamos a fijarnos en esto si
por ejemplo nos fijamos en los 4
electrones de valencia verdad que
tenemos digamos y los si nos fijamos en
ellos en la anotación de los orbitales
que tenemos en esta tabla eso
corresponde a estos 4 déjenme marcarlos
con otro color corresponde a estos 4
electrones que tenemos por aquí verdad
pero eso implicaría que el carbono solo
podría formar dos enlaces porque tenemos
estos dos electrones que no tienen
pareja justamente aquí verdad y por
supuesto todo esto tiene distintos
niveles de energía y por lo tanto lo que
veríamos de manera experimental con no
corresponde con la estructura de puntos
verdad no no no no cacha digamos la idea
de la configuración electrónica queremos
aquí verdad así que para explicar esa
diferencia linus pauling vino
con la idea de hibridación y lo primero
que dijo fue lo siguiente que podríamos
tomar estos electrones que tenemos en el
orbital 12 y podríamos eliminar uno de
ellos digamos podríamos quitar este de
aquí y moverlo a uno de los orbitales p
que tenemos justamente aquí
ok justamente como lo hemos movido hasta
este momento así que ya lo movimos a
este orbital p y ahora estamos en un
estado excitado verdad así que tenemos
la oportunidad para el carbono de formar
cuatro enlaces sin embargo estos
electrones no no son digamos
equivalentes en el sentido de energía
así que linus pauling dijo que hagamos
algo algo más vamos a promover este
orbital 2s vamos a vamos a moverlo
digamos
dirección ok vamos a ponerlo digamos
aquí y lo que estamos pensando con esta
imagen es que estamos promoviendo la
digamos la energía que tiene este
orbital y en caso contrario con estos
orbitales vamos a disminuir su energía
digamos ok entonces tenemos aquí estos
cuatro orbitales en donde uno de ellos
corresponde al orbital ese y tres de
ellos a orbitales p muy bien y por
supuesto cada uno de ellos tenía un
electrón en cada uno de ellos aunque ahí
tenemos un electrón en cada uno de estos
orbitales y finalmente lo que vamos a
hacer es hibridar los es decir éste ya
no va a ser un orbital ese va a ser un
orbital sp3 éste ya no va a ser un
orbital p va a ser un orbital sp3 y lo
mismo pasa con nosotros orbitales verdad
va a ser un esp 3 es decir estamos
hibridando los orbitales
la idea central es que estamos tomando
un poco digamos de las características y
un poco de las características y estamos
hibridando los todos juntos en nuevos
órbita en nuevos orbitales verdad y como
estamos tomando parte de un orbital ese
y tres orbitales p estamos por eso es
que se les conoce como orbitales
híbridos sp3 y así obtenemos lo que
estábamos buscando porque ahora tenemos
cuatro electrones que no tienen su
pareja verdad así que el carbono puede
formar cuatro enlaces nuevos y digamos
son iguales en energía así que es la
idea de la hibridación muy bien ahora
vamos a pensar en las características o
en la figura que tienen estos nuevos
orbitales nosotros sabemos que los
orbitales s tienen digamos como una
figura de tipo más o menos esférico
verdad
el tipo esférico que tenemos en los
orbitales es verdad y tenemos uno solo
estamos tomando un orbital ese y sabemos
que los orbitales p tienen como ésta
esta forma del lóbulo verdad
del lóbulo y debería corregir esta
segunda parte porque debe ser igual
verdad y de esto tenemos tres entonces
qué es lo que obtenemos vamos a tener
ahora cuatro figuras que más o menos son
de tipo lóbulo por arriba pero tienen
una un lóbulo mucho más pequeño por
abajo verdad ahora digamos que el
orbital final digamos el orbital híbrido
final contiene digamos el 25 por ciento
de características s mientras que el 75
por ciento tiene características del
orbital p
y nuevamente esto se debe simplemente
porque partimos de un orbital ese y tres
orbitales
muy bien entonces vamos a volver al
metano ahora nosotros sabemos que este
carbono tiene una hibridación sp3 así
que vamos a tratar de hacer un dibujo
por aquí abajo
así que primero pintemos nuestro carbono
ahí tenemos nuestro carbono y vamos a
dibujar los cuatro orbitales sp3 verdad
y nuevamente cuando dibujamos las
órbitas con los orbitales perdón vamos a
ignorar los digamos estos lóbulos
pequeños que tenemos por detrás verdad
así que esto es sólo para que no nos
confunda tenemos
los cuatro orbitales digamos tenemos
aquí en este día
otro orbital y el cuarto verdad
y finalmente tenemos que mostrar por
supuesto que cada uno de estos orbitales
tiene un electrón en el ok ahí están
nuestros cuatro electrones que de hecho
lo podemos ver justamente de aquí que
cada uno de estos tiene está en un en un
nuevo orbital digamos el tipo sp3 verdad
que es híbrido muy bien entonces ahí
tenemos nuestro electrón en cada uno de
ellos y cuando estamos hablando del
metano nosotros sabemos que el carbono
está unido a cuatro hidrógenos verdad y
cada hidrógeno tiene un orbital ese que
es que no está hibridado verdad así que
cada hidrógeno va a tener un orbital
efe que no está híbrida de verdad
de ellos tiene
uno de estos orbitales es verdad y aquí
tenemos nuestros cuatro hidrógenos 1 2 3
4 verdad y tiene su electrón en este
orbital ahí está
los 4 electrones correspondientes a los
hidrógenos esto es simplemente una
digamos una imagen de lo que sería la
molécula del metano verdad todos esos
hidrógenos ya los hemos puesto y podemos
observar que en el enlace se forma
justamente aquí déjenme marcarlo con
otro color los enlaces se forman
justamente aquí en donde tenemos un
traslape entre los orbitales esto es
justamente donde se forman los enlaces y
es justamente porque estamos
compartiendo electrones verdad y esto en
química se le conoce como los enlaces
sigma todos estos corresponden a enlaces
muy bien entonces en vez de decir que
tenemos enlaces simples o digamos
simples se refiere a que solo es digamos
lo que tenemos en la estructura de
puntos como una sola línea verdad esto
simplemente en química se le conoce como
enlace sigma y como podemos observar en
este dibujo en realidad nosotros tenemos
cuatro enlaces y ahora vamos a fijarnos
en la molécula del etano muy bien
entonces si nos fijamos en la molécula
del etano recordemos que su fórmula
molecular es de 2 h 6 verdad y si
tratamos de dibujar su estructura de
puntos aunque tenemos 2 carbonos unidos
y luego podemos pintar los 6 hidrógenos
verdad justamente
vemos 34
6 tenemos
en total 6 hidrógenos
y justamente si queremos hacer un
análisis similar nosotros ya hemos visto
que un carbono con cuatro enlaces
simples pues va a tener una hibridación
sp3 verdad esto va a tener una
hibridación sp3 justamente digamos
siguiendo la misma el mismo argumento
que con el metano verdad que aquí
teníamos una hibridación sp3 entonces
estos dos carbonos que tenemos en el
etano tienen una hibridación sp3 vamos
vamos a tratar de dibujar cómo se vería
esto
a poner más espacio un poco más de
espacio y tenemos nuestro carbono que
tenemos del lado izquierdo verdad y
tendremos sus cuatro orbitales híbridos
sp3 muy bien tenemos estos
los 34 orbitales y del lado izquierdo
tenemos otro carbono verdad que también
tiene cuatro orbitales híbridos y estos
dos se traslapan para formar un enlace
sigma verdad por supuesto tiene sus
otros tres orbitales y ahí tenemos más o
menos un esbozo inicial de lo que es
esta molécula y recordemos que en cada
uno de estos orbitales hay un electrón
verdad y aquí por supuesto como hay un
traslape pues lo comparten dos
electrones
y tenemos el resto de los electrones
finalmente hay que agregar los hidro
genes verdad tenemos
6 hidrógenos con sólo un orbital s que
no está híbrida de verdad aquí tenemos
un hidrógeno verdad y para hacerlo más
rápido simplemente voy a poner estos
orbitales s
s que corresponden a los hidrógenos
verdad
vamos a ahorrar tiempo bueno vamos a
poner que estos son hidrógenos todos
estos de color azul corresponden a
hidrógenos entonces si nos preguntamos
cuántos enlaces sigma tenemos en esta
molécula pues simplemente tenemos que
calcular obtenemos que observar más bien
cuántos traslapes de orbitales podemos
hallar y aquí hasta este momento
llevamos 4 5 6 y finalmente recordemos
que estos dos orbitales híbridos se
trasladan entonces lo que tenemos son
siete enlaces
muy bien
y esto por supuesto lo podemos verificar
en la estructura de puntos verdad aquí
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis y
siete enlaces sigma que son los enlaces
simples
vamos a irnos digamos a la última parte
y vamos a centrarnos en el enlace que
tenemos entre los dos carbonos verdad
vamos a fijarnos justamente en este
enlace de aquí y ahí tenemos por
supuesto un enlace sigma que además
tiene una rotación libre por por ser un
enlace sigma ok entonces este enlace
tiene una rotación libre digamos ok y
con esto queremos decir que los carbonos
pueden rotar en el espacio digamos con
con esta dirección y eso le va a dar
distintas conformaciones ok podríamos
tener distintas conformaciones para la
molécula del etano y que es algo que
vamos a entrar en detalle en vídeos
posteriores así que si tenemos una
rotación libre alrededor de los enlaces
sin más déjenme déjenme escribirlo esto
es una rotación libre aunque pueden
rotar en el espacio alrededor o digamos
en esta dirección en los enlaces sigma y
eso nos va a permitir tener distintas
conformaciones para esta molécula y lo
último que quiero remarcar es que para
esta molécula
del etano ok si nos fijamos en es en la
longitud que hay en este enlace
la longitud entre estos dos carbonos
digamos resulta ser aproximadamente
aproximadamente de 1.54 amstrong
y por supuesto dependiendo el libro de
texto que esté revisando puede ser que
tengas distintos valores ligeramente
distintos verdad pero digamos que
aproximadamente corresponde a este valor
y la razón por la cual es necesario
conocer esto es porque vamos a comparar
este tipo de enlaces entre carbonos y
vamos a compararlos en términos de su
longitud verdad de la longitud del
enlace y vamos a compararlo con otras
moléculas en otros vídeos